Le 10 septembre, au matin de mon septième anniversaire,
Je suis descendue dans la cuisine, où ma mère faisait la vaisselle
et mon père lisait le journal,
je me suis arrêtée sur le pas de la porte, et ils m'ont dit,
"Joyeux anniversaire". Et j'ai répondu, "j'ai sept ans."
Mon père a souri et dit:
"Tu sais ce que cela signifie, n'est-ce pas ?"
J'ai dit "Oui, que je vais avoir une fête et un gâteau
et plein de cadeaux ?". Mon pere a dit "eh bien, oui,
mais, et c'est plus important, à 7 ans tu as atteint l'âge de raison,
et tu peux donc commettre tous les péchés contre Dieu et les hommes."
(Rires)
J'avais déjà entendu parler de cette expression, "l'âge de raison"
Soeur Marie Kevin nous en avait parlé sans cesse
dans ma classe de CE1. Mais quand elle en parlait,
l'expression était prise dans l'excitation des préparatifs
de notre première communion et confession;
tout le monde savait que l'important c'était la robe blanche et le voile,
et je n'avais pas vraiment fait attention à cette expression "l'âge de raison"
J'ai donc dit "Oui, oui, l'âge de raison, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire déjà ?"
Mon père m'a dit "Et bien, les catholiques pensent que
Dieu sait que les petits enfants ne font pas la différence entre le bien et le mal
mais à sept ans, tu sais ce que tu fais.
Tu es grande, tu as atteint l'age de raison, et maintenant
Dieu prend des notes sur toi et commence ton dossier permanent."
(Rires)
Alors j'ai dit "Oh. Mais attendez, vous voulez dire que tout ce temps,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui, quand je faisais des bonnes actions, Dieu ne l'a pas remarqué ?"
Et ma mère m'a dit, "Moi, j'ai remarqué"
(Rires)
Je me suis dit "Pourquoi est-ce que je ne savais pas ça avant ?
Pourquoi je n'ai pas enregistré ça quand ils m'en parlaient ?
Toutes ces bonnes actions et pas de récompense.
Et, le pire, c'est que j'avais appris cette information de la plus haute importance
le jour où cette information m'était inutile"
J'ai donc dit "Mais, papa, maman, et le père Noël ?
je veux dire, le père Noël sait si on a été bon ou mauvais, pas vrai ?"
Et mon père m'a dit "Oui, mais, ma chérie,
je pense que ça ne compte qu'entre Thankgiving et Noël."
Et ma mère a dit : "oh, Bob, allons. On peut le lui dire.
Elle a sept ans après tout. Julie, il n'y a pas de Père Noël."
(Rires)
Bon, cette nouvelle ne m'a pas trop bouleversée.
Mes parents avaient cette explication compliquée à propos du père Noël ;
Ils lui avaient parlé et avaient décidé ensemble
qu'au lieu de nous amener des cadeaux le soir du réveillon
comme il le faisait pour toutes les autres familles
qui pouvaient ouvrir leurs cadeaux le matin de Noël
notre famille laisserait plus de temps au père Noël :
il viendrait pendant que nous étions à la messe de 9 heures
le matin de Noël, mais seulement si tous les enfants étaient calmes
Cela m'avait rendu bien suspicieuse.
C'était clair que c'était nos parents qui nous donnaient les cadeaux.
Mon père avait un style très particulier pour emballer les cadeaux,
et l'écriture de ma mère était très proche de celle du père Noël.
Et puis, pourquoi le père Noël chercherait-il à gagner du temps, en revenant
nous voir après avoir visité tout le monde ?
Il n'y avait qu'une conclusion à tirer de cette montagne de preuves :
notre famille était trop étrange et bizarre
même pour le père Noël,
et nos pauvres parents tentaient de nous protéger de la honte,
de l'humiliation d'etre rejetés par le père Noël, qui est joyeux,
mais il faut bien l'avouer, très critique.
Donc, quand j'ai appris qu'il n'y avait pas de père Noël du tout, c'était une sorte de soulagement.
J'ai quitté la cuisine sans être choquée à cause du père Noël,
mais j'étais abasourdie
par le fait que j'avais manqué cette histoire d'âge de raison.
C'était trop tard pour moi, mais je pouvais peut-être aider quelqu'un d'autre,
quelqu'un qui pourrait utiliser l'information.
Ils devaient correspondre à deux critères :
ils devaient être assez âgés pour comprendre
le concept d'âge de raison, mais avoir moins de sept ans.
La réponse était simple : mon frère Bill, qui avait six ans.
J'ai fini par trouver Bill à un pâté de maisons de chez nous,
dans la cour de récré de l'école. C'était un samedi,
et il était tout seul, en train de taper un ballon contre un mur.
J'ai couru vers lui et j'ai dit "Bill !
Je viens d'apprendre que l'âge de raison démarre quand on a sept ans,
à partir de là tu peux commettre toutes sortes de péchés
contre Dieu et les hommes". Et bill dit "Et alors ?". Alors j'ai dit,
"Alors ? Tu as six ans, tu as un an pour faire tout ce que tu veux
et Dieu ne fait pas attention" Il a encore dit "et alors ?" et j'ai dit
"Et alors ? Alors tout !" et je suis partie en courant. J'étais en colère contre lui
Mais quand j'ai atteint le haut des marches, je me suis retournée
et dit "Oh, et au fait Bill : le Père Noël n'existe pas"
(Rires)
En revanche, je ne le savais pas à l'époque,
mais je n'ai pas eu sept ans le 10 septembre.
Pour mes 13 ans, j'organisai une fête pour mes amies
mais quelques semaines avantt ma mère m'a prise à part et m'a dit
"il faut que je te parle.
Ton anniversaire n'est pas le 10 septembre. C'est le 10 octobre. Et j'ai dit "Quoi ?"
(Rires)
Elle a dit "Écoute, la date limite pour l'entrée en maternelle était le 15 septembre"
"Et donc, je leur ait dit que ton anniversaire était le 10 septembre
et pour être sûre que tu ne vendes pas la mèche,
j'ai commencé à te dire que ton anniversaire était le 10 septembre.
Mais, Julie, tu étais prête à aller à l'école, ma chérie, tu étais tout à fait prête
Mais quand j'y pense, quand j'avais 4 ans,
j'étais la plus âgée des 4 enfants,
et ma mère était enceinte,
donc je pense que ce qu'elle voulait dire est qu'elle était tout à fait prête,
Elle était tout à fait prête. Puis elle a dit,
"Ne t'inquiète pas Julie, tous les ans le 10 octobre, quand c'était ton anniversaire
mais que tu ne le savais pas, je m'assurais
que tu manges un morceau de gâteau."
(Rires)
Ce qui était réconfortant, mais inquiétant.
Ma mère avait fêté mon anniversaire avec moi, mais sans moi.
Ce qui m'embêtait le plus dans cette histoire
n'était pas que je devais changer la date de la fête
avec mes amies,
ce qui m'embêtait c'était que je n'étais plus du signe de la Vierge.
j'avais un poster de ce signe dans ma chambre
je lisais mon horoscope tous les jours, et ça me correspondait complètement.
(Rires)
J'était donc du signe de la balance ?
Je suis allée en ville pour acheter le poster de la balance.
Le poster de la vierge représente une belle femme aux cheveux longs,
qui se prélasse au bord de l'eau,
Mais le nouveau poster n'est qu'une énorme balance.
C'est à cette époque que j'ai commencé à grossir,
et j'ai grossi plus que beaucoup d'autres filles,
et, franchement, le fait que mon signe soit une balance
me semblait de mauvais augure et déprimant.
(Rires)
Mais quand j'ai acheté le poster
et que j'ai commencé à lire l'horoscope de la balance,
j'ai été surprise de trouver que ça me correspondait parfaitement aussi
Et ce n'est que des années plus tard, en repensant
à cette histoire d'âge de raison / changement d'anniversaire,
que j'ai réalisé que je n'avais pas sept ans
quand je pensais avoir sept ans. J'avais eu tout un mois
pour faire ce que je voulais avant que Dieu commence à me surveiller.
Oh, la vie est si cruelle.
Un jour, deux missionnaires mormons sont venus à ma porte.
J'habite à côté d'un grand axe de Los Angeles,
et mon quartier est un point de départ fréquent
pour ceux qui font du porte-à-porte.
Parfois, des vieilles dames de l'Église Adventiste du Septième Jour
me montrent des dessins du paradis.
Et parfois, des jeunes viennent et me promettent qu'ils ne rejoindront pas un gang
et n'agresseront pas les gens si seulement je leur achetais
quelques abonnements à des magazines.
D'habitude je ne réponds pas quand on sonne à ma porte, mais pas cette fois-ci.
A la porte se trouvaient deux garçons, d'environ 19 ans,
en chemises blanches à manches courtes, et ils portaient des badges
les identifiant comme étant des représentants officiels
de l'Église de Jésus-Christ des saints des derniers jours.
Ils m'ont dit avoir un message pour moi de la part de Dieu.
J'ai dit "un message pour moi ? de Dieu" Et ils ont dit "Oui."
J'ai été élevée dans le nord-ouest des États-Unis,
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de membres de l'Église des saints des derniers jours;
J'ai travaillé avec eux, je suis même sortie avec certains.
Mais je ne connaissais pas vraiment leur doctrine, et ce qu'ils disaient aux gens
quand ils faisaient du porte-à-porte, et je pense que j'étais curieuse,
alors je leur ai dit "Et bien, rentrez", et ils ont eu l'air très heureux,
parce que je pense que cela ne leur arrive pas si souvent.
(Rires)
Ils se sont assis, et je leur ai offert de l'eau --
OK, c'est bon. Je leur ai donné à boire.
Ne touchez pas à mes cheveux, surtout.
(Rires)
Vous ne pouvez pas me mettre une vidéo de moi devant les yeux
et penser que je ne vais pas toucher ma coiffure.
(Rires)
OK. Donc je les ai fait s'assoir et leur ai donné un verre d'eau,
Et après les politesses ils ont dit "Croyez vous que Dieu vous aime de tout son coeur ?"
J'ai pensé "Et bien, bien sûr je crois en Dieu,
mais je n'aime pas ce mot, "coeur",
car ça anthropomorphise Dieu,
et je n'aime pas le mot "il", car ça sexualise Dieu"
Mais je ne voulais pas débattre de sémantique avec eux,
donc, après un long silence gêné, j'ai dit
"Oui, je me sens aimée."
Ils se sont regardés et ont souri,
j'avais donné la bonne réponse. Puis ils ont dit
"Croyez-vous que nous sommes tous frères et soeurs sur cette planète ?"
J'ai répondu "Oui, je le pense, oui", et j'étais contente
d'avoir eu une question à laquelle je pouvais répondre si rapidement.
Puis ils ont dit "Et bien, nous avons une histoire à vous conter".
Ils m'on racontée l'histoire d'un homme appelé Lehi,
qui vivait à Jérusalem en 600 avant Jesus Christ.
À cette époque, apparemment,
tout le monde était mauvais et méchant. Tout le monde :
les hommes, les femmes, les enfants, les foetus.
Dieu est apparu à Lehi et lui a dit "Met ta famille sur un bateau
et je vous guiderai hors d'ici". Et Dieu les a guidés.
Ils les a guidés jusqu'en Amérique.
J'ai dit "En Amérique ? De Jérusalem jusqu'en Amérique, en bateau, en 600 av. J.-C. ?"
Et ils m'ont dit "Oui."
(Rires)
Puis ils m'ont dit que Lehi et ses descendants
se sont reproduits, et qu'au bout de 600 ans
Ils étaient séparés en deux races : les Nephites et les Lamanites,
les Nephites étaient tous complètement bons - tous autant qu'ils étaient -
et les Lamanites étaient tous complètement mauvais et méchants.
tous jusqu'au dernier, mauvais jusqu'à la moëlle.
(Rires)
Ensuite, après que Jesus soit mort sur la croix pour nos péchés,
avant d'aller au Paradis, il s'est arrêté en Amérique pour rencontrer les Nephites.
(Rires)
Il leur a dit que s'ils restaient bons,
tous complètement bons,
ils gagneraient la guerre contre les méchants Lamanites.
Mais apparemment quelqu'un a gaffé,
car les Lamanites ont réussi à tuer tous les Nephites.
Tous sauf un, un homme appelé Mormon,
qui a survécu en se cachant dans la forêt.
Il a écrit son histoire
en hiéroglyphes égyptiens modernes, gravés sur des plaques d'or,
qu'il a ensuite enterrées près de Palmyra, état de New York.
(Rires)
J'étais fébrile.
J'ai demandé "que sont devenus les Lamanites ?"
Ils m'ont dit "et bien, ils sont devenus les Indiens d'Amérique"
J'ai dit "Vous croyez donc que les Indiens d'Amérique sont les descendants
d'un peuple complètement mauvais et méchant ?" Et ils m'ont dit "Oui."
Puis ils m'ont raconté la façon dont un homme, Joseph Smith,
a trouvé ces plaques d'or dans son jardin,
ainsi qu'une pierre magique qui, quand il la mettait dans son chapeau
lui permettait
de traduire l'égyptien moderne en anglais.
À ce moment je voulais conseiller ces deux garçons
à propos de leur accroche.
(Rires)
Je voulais leur dire "Ne commencez pas par cette histoire"
Même les scientologues savent qu'ils doivent commencer par un test de personnalité --
(Applaudissements)
-- avant de leur parler de Xenu, le dictateur de la Fédération galactique.
Ils m'ont ensuite dit "Pensez-vous que Dieu nous parle
à travers ses justes prophètes ?" Et j'ai répondu que non.
Car j'étais énervée par cette histoire de Lamanites
et de tablettes en or. Mais en vérité,
je n'y avais pas vraiment réfléchi, alors j'ai pris un peu de recul et dit
"Et bien, qu'est ce que vous entendez par juste ?
Et que voulez-vous dire par prophètes ? Est-ce que les prophètes peuvent être des femmes ?"
Et ils m'ont répondu que non. J'ai dit "Pourquoi ?", et ils m'ont dit
"Et bien, parce que Dieu a donné aux femmes un don si exceptionnel,
si merveilleux, que le seul don qu'il lui restait à donner aux hommes
était le don de prophétie."
Je me suis demandée quel était ce don merveilleux, donné par Dieu aux femmes ?
Leur meilleure aptitude à coopérer et s'adapter ?
Leur plus grande espérance de vie ? Le fait que les femmes ont tendance à être
beaucoup moins violentes que les hommes ? Non, ce n'était rien de tout cela.
Ils m'ont dit "C'est de pouvoir donner naissance aux enfants."
J'ai répondu "Allons, même si les femmes essayaient d'enfanter
tous les ans depuis l'âge de 15 ans jusqu'à 45 ans,
en admettant qu'elles ne meurent pas d'épuisement,
je pense que quelques femmes auraient le temps
d'entendre la parole de Dieu". Ils m'ont répondu "Non."
(Rires)
À partir de là ils ne me semblaient plus si sympathiques;
mais ils avaient encore à dire.
Ils m'ont dit "Nous croyons aussi que si vous êtes Mormon
et que vous êtes dans les bonnes grâces de l'Église, à votre mort
vous allez au Paradis, et serez avec votre famille pour l'éternité
J'ai répondu "Oh --
(Rires)
ça ne m'attire pas vraiment."
Puis ils ont dit "Oh -- aussi, nous croyons
qu'au Paradis, votre corps vous est rendu
dans son état d'origine.
Par exemple, si vous avez perdu une jambe, vous l'avez à nouveau.
Ou, si vous êtes devenu aveugle, vous pourrez voir à nouveau".
Je leur ai dit "Oh. je n'ai plus d'utérus à cause d'un cancer
il y a quelques années. Est-ce-que ça veut dire qu'au paradis
je retrouverai mon utérus ?" Ils m'ont dit "oui, bien sûr"
J'ai dit "mais je n'en veux pas, je suis heureuse sans !"
Et si vous aviez été opéré du nez et que ça vous plaisait ?
(Rires)
Est-ce que Dieu vous forcerait à reprendre votre ancien nez ?
Enfin, ils m'ont donné le Livre des Mormons,
m'ont dit de lire tels et tels chapitres,
et m'ont dit qu'ils repasseraient un jour pour voir comment j'allais.
J'ai répondu quelque chose comme "ne vous pressez pas"
ou peut être juste "non merci", et ils sont partis.
Bon. Au départ je me sentais vraiment supérieure à ces garçons,
et fière de ma foi plus conventionnelle. Mais ensuite,
plus j'y pensais, plus je me devais d'être honnête.
Si quelqu'un était venu à ma porte pour me raconter la théologie catholique
pour la première fois, en me disant
"Nous croyons que Dieu à rendu enceinte une très jeune fille
sans rapport sexuel,
et le fait qu'elle était vierge est super important --
(Rires)
-- et elle a eu un enfant, qui est le fils de Dieu,"
J'aurais trouvé ça tout aussi ridicule.
Je suis juste habituée à cette histoire là.
(Rires)
Je ne pouvais plus être condescendante envers ces deux garçons.
Mais la première question qu'ils m'ont posée en arrivant
m'est restée en tête :
Est-ce que je croyais que Dieu m'aimait de tout son coeur ?
Car je n'étais pas sûre de ma réponse
S'ils m'avaient demandé
Sentez-vous que Dieu vous aime de tout son coeur ?
Ca aurait été différent, je crois que j'aurais répondu immédiatement
Oui, oui, je le sens en permanence. Je sens l'amour de Dieu quand je suis blessée et perdue,
je me sens consolée et protegée. Je suis à l'abri dans l'amour de Dieu
quand je me demande pourquoi quelque chose de tragique arrive,
et je sens l'amour de Dieu quand je vois avec gratitude la beauté qui nous entoure"
Mais comme ils m'ont posé cette question avec le mot "croire",
c'était différent,
car je n'étais pas sûre de croire ce que je ressentais si clairement.